if you're just joining us we are closely
following the demise of the tablet
market and the chaos that's ensued in
order to save the big screen slabs for
the good of humankind tablets have
gained keyboards and software features
in hopes that we'll choose them over
laptops Microsoft did it with the
surface Apple has done it for the iPad
pro and this just in today Google is
launching its own the pixel sea is a
five hundred dollar 10.2 inch Android
tablet with an optional 150 dollar
keyboard dock about three hundred and
fifty dollars less than the iPad pro in
the surface pro and about the same as a
mid-range laptop well this could be the
one that ends the crisis right not quite
hardware wise there's a lot I like even
love the aluminum tablet is light has a
beautiful crisp screen and gets 10 hours
of battery life but its biggest selling
point is the Bluetooth keyboard which
magnetically latches to the tablet when
you aren't using it ready to write your
great novel or tweet place the tablet on
it like so and then lift to prop it up
it's more sturdy than the iPads keyboard
case and even better on a lap and the
surfaces the smaller 10-inch screen
which is smaller than the iPad pro in
the surface does make typing more
cramped though the smaller screen held
me back from getting more done but not
as much as the Android software did most
apps have not been optimized for the
bigger horizontal screen and they lack
features you want on a device that's
about being more productive even
Google's Chrome lacks extras like
pinning tabs plus you can't place apps
side-by-side like you can in iOS windows
and even Samsung's Android tablets and
the alt tab keyboard shortcut does let
you flip through apps but I was
constantly reaching out to touch the
screen hold on my producers telling me
we have a special guest on the line mr.
Android thank you for joining us vince
stern that's not fair we have optimized
games and apps like Google photos for
the pixel fair point mr. Android but
this really gets to the heart of the
tablet crisis we are still looking for
that perfect laptop tablet balance as a
tablet to read and surf the web the
pixel C is good but it's simply not a
good get stuff
done tablet certainly not as good as the
surface crow or even the iPad pro if
you're looking for a laptop that's good
at Google things save yourself some
money and get the $250 Toshiba
Chromebook to that of course means the
tablet crisis and our coverage of it
continues stay with us we'll be back
soon